ااا عندما تنتهي رحله كريستيانو رونالدو
في مونديال 2022 ربما لن تتوجه طائرته الى
مانشستر او حتى الى موطنه الاصلي
البرتغالي الدون او صاروخ ماديرا كما
يلقبه عشاقه قد يكون على موعد مع رحله
ومغامره جديده في الملاعب السعوديه وصى
انباء موسىواتي عن عرض سعوديه
غير مؤكده قد يكون قدمه نادي النصر
السعودي كما تشير الانباء حيث ينتظر ان
يرد عليه رونالدو خلال الايام المقبله بعد
كاس العالم الذي يلعب فيه رونالدو للمره
الاخيره في حياته الرياضيه يرغب رونالدو
في نهائي مسيرته بتحقيق لقب عالميا جديد
مع منتخب البرتغالي يقرر مصيره بعد نهايه
المونديال بعد فسقي عقبه بالتراضي مع
ناديه السابق مانشستر يونايتد اثر
تصريحاته التي هاجم فيها اداره ومدرب
الفريق الانجليزي
على كل حال نقعدوا معكم من القصه الكامله
لفكره انتقال رونالدو الى الدوري السعودي
مع علاء
قصه انتقال رونالدو الى السعوديه تعود
باصداء قويه الاحاديث كثيره ومتابعوا
الكره العالميه ربما ينتظرون انتقالا
تاريخيا للاعب الابرز في تاريخ اللعبه
الحديث الحكايه بدات في الصيف الماضي مع
انباء عن وجود عرضا سعودي للنجم البرتغالي
الذي بدات مشاكله مع نادي مانشستر يونايتد
في ذلك الوقت رونالدو حينها كان يرغب
بالرحيل عن اليونايتد الذي لم يتاهل لدوري
ابطال اوروبا طرق ابواب انديه اوروبيه
اخرى وحاول الخروج لكن اداره يونايتد لم
تقبل راتبه المرتفع حاله دون انتقاله
لانديه اخرى انتهت فتره الانتقالات استمر
رونالدو في الاشهر الاولى من الموسم
الجديد مع مانشستر يونايتد على العلاقه
كانت بارده مع الاداره ومدرب النادي ختمها
رونالدو بتصريحات سبقت كاس العالم هاجم
فيها
قتل نادي والمدرب الانجليزيه بدا كاس
العالم الاهتمامات منصبه على اهم حدث
عالمي لكن حكايه اقتراب بانتقال رونالدو
من نادي النصر السعودي سرقت بعض الاضواء
من المونديال حيث الصفقه التي يقدرها
البعض باكثر من 250 مليون دولار امريكي
لمده ثلاث سنوات
[موسيقى]
اجمل شيء قبل ما تكملي بس يعني من عشاق
رونالدو كريستيانو ييجي للدوري السعودي
ويكون في منتخب عربي بصير قريب عربي
[ضحك]